okay your journey
I just did one like them together I just
did one oh good literally like a day ago
did you win escaped with three minutes a
little over three minutes left that's
what I'm saying yes yes I love escape
rooms okay I've I've counted so far I've
done almost to 80 Escape rooms because
you do it on tour I did it on tour yes
but I I will do four in a night like I
will be wiped my friends are like let's
go out and I'm like I'm gonna lock
myself in a room
and just try to find my way out and my
friends are like why does that sound fun
I'm like it is I just I love it I think
it's so it gets me stimulated I feel
accomplished and yeah are you good at it
are you really good I'm not that good at
it me neither me neither but it's like
bowling really you just like to be there
you know it's a good time to be there
it's a good hang I love it too it's
amazing how you see your friends too how
they operate in that environment totally
yeah I take it serious though and like
guys we're in a movie you're playing the
lead character yeah I somehow get lost
you know yeah I make it a whole scenario
yeah oh I'm totally into we all just did
it the band we were all there yeah
anyway okay those are our
foreign
Selena Gomez my mind and me is on Apple
TV plus now y'all have to watch it it's
so good Selena Gomez everybody Give It
Up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
I'm going
everybody
[Music]